the January 6th house committee
investigating the Trump riots
isn't going to last much longer and the
reason is that the house is being taken
over by Republicans in January because
Republicans won the 2022 midterms in the
house see how I say that without any
qualifications see how I just say
Democrats won the Senate but Republicans
won the house I don't have to rant and
Rave and say because of rigging or
because of fraud or fraud or because of
seasoned ballots or smoke ballots or
sauteed or sous vide ballots just
Republicans won the house and Democrats
won the Senate see how easy it is for me
to say that okay because that's what
happened in November
um and and really anyway because
Congress is ending and any investigative
committees would have to be
reconstituted in the next Congress the
January 6th Committee of the house is
going to end but it is not yet over they
told us some months ago that they would
come back with a couple of final
hearings sometime before the end of the
year I don't know if that's still going
to take place but yesterday there was a
very important bit of news that was
announced the house January 6 committee
has decided to make criminal referrals
let me remind you so we're all on the
same page one of the guidelines of house
committees remember the House of
Representative uh the House of
Representatives has investigative duties
and responsibilities and abilities
they do not have primary criminal
referral responsibility meaning the
house is not supposed to take on an
investigation
primarily or solely to determine whether
criminal activity took place however it
is well within the purview of the House
of Representatives investigative duties
to make criminal referrals if in
investigating whatever they are
investigating they come across what they
believe to be based on the advice of the
lawyers that work with them criminal
activity that is exactly what the house
committee says it found CNN reports the
house select committee investigating the
January 6 2021 attack on the U.S Capitol
has decided to make criminal referrals
to the Department of Justice according
to Congressman Benny Thompson Thompson's
a Mississippi Democrat and said the
committee has not yet narrowed down the
universe of individuals who may be
referred of course that's code for we've
not yet ruled out a criminal referral
against the failed former president
Donald Trump asked whether Thompson
believed any of the witnesses perjured
themselves he said quote that's part of
the discussion
when the panel makes referrals Thompson
said it will be a separate document from
the panel's final report that will be
sent to the doj a select committee
spokesperson confirmed to CNN that
criminal referrals will be considered as
a final part of the panel's work the
spokesperson said quote the committee
has determined that referrals to outside
entities should be considered as a final
part of its work the committee will make
decisions about specifics in the days
ahead a source tells CNN the criminal
referrals the January 6 committee will
ultimately be making quote will be
focused on the main organizers and
leaders of the attack so one of the
major obvious pressing questions is is
Trump seen in this particular context by
this committee based on the work they've
done as one of the main leaders and
organizers of the attack and if so is
there going to be a criminal referral
directly to Donald Trump now it's
important to remind people I have no
interest in aggrandizing or minimizing
what may or may not take place here
the question of course if the doj
receives a criminal referral from the
House of Representatives for Trump
is whether they actually decide to
charge him there's no guarantee just
because a criminal referral is made that
Trump is actually going to be charged
perjury also if indeed it took place uh
by those who did testify if there are if
perjury took place it would be nice to
see perjury charges which are very
difficult to prove but we just don't
know about that many people writing to
me and saying David do you know if the
referrals will be made public or will it
be behind the scenes my understanding
from looking at this article and others
is that it will be a separate document
that will contain the referrals but it
will be made public that the evidence is
public the testimony has been public and
the referrals will also be made public
now I want this all to move quickly
we all do it's been years with a lot of
this stuff at the same time it makes
sense that the January 6 committee has
taken a measured approach they've
calculated it they've done everything by
the book They're with strategy and it
shows and this really was carried out in
a way that despite and in the context of
massive Republican obstruction because
remember there was initially a deal to
have significantly more Republican
representation on this committee and
Republicans refused to participate
because they wanted the committee to
focus on different things they had all
sorts of rules that they wanted which
made no sense so ultimately the
committee was assembled with a few
Republicans Adam kinzinger uh Liz Cheney
um is that all right now I don't
remember uh but in any case it was by
their own doing that this was the format
of the committee now we have a time
limit there's a new house led by
Republicans which will be sworn in
within a few weeks this is the end of
the committee but it may only be the
beginning of the Criminal part as far as
the doj is concerned Next Step let's see
what the referrals show and then go from
there we will have all of today's
stories and the clips and feedback and
more
on the Facebook page make sure you have
liked the David Pacman show on Facebook
at facebook.com
slash slash is important and adapt to
forward slash not a backslash David
packman show quick break and be right
back